centuries ago explorers set out from the
city of porto in hopes of conquering the
world
today portugal is mired in crisis
jose pulido valente too has been
struggling to keep his head above water
that's why he converted his house to
three holiday apartments he furnished
and decorated them himself and plans to
charge about 1 000 euros a week he's
hopeful that the risk will pay off
i
want to
give them a different type of
of apartment so i can
have a price not so low
than the others here in porto that are
very cheap
and
to have
the possibility to earn some money
valenta hasn't been able to earn a
living as an architect for years now the
crisis hit the construction industry
hard and many companies went under
but now the government has announced a
program to invest 6 billion euros on
infrastructure the country's
construction association estimates that
will increase demand by 40 percent
manuel reyes campos says the time is
ripe to exit europe's bailout program
is important
leaving the rescue program will create
change portugal is growing again that's
the most important thing for me
i don't just want us to exit the bailout
i want us to leave at the right moment
and to take advantage of the situation
we're in
is a professor of economics at the
university of porto
she's been following the government's
plans closely and she believes the
investment program doesn't go far enough
about a quarter of portugal's population
is at risk of poverty
people suffer a lot and i'm afraid we
will still suffer in the
long times people
are still say well we have a lot of
taxes taxes are increasing my wages are
becoming smaller and smaller every day
but i don't see how this is helping us
to go out of the crisis
melancholy and misfortune are also
themes in portugal's traditional photo
music
it's popular with visitors too
tourism is just about the only truly
thriving industry here
soja venus is a well-known port wine
producer over the past six years the
number of visitors at their facility has
nearly doubled and the company is doing
well on the export market sixty percent
of their wines are sold abroad it's
especially popular in china and russia
last year we had two thousand two two
hundred and twenty five thousand visits
it's a lot
in the group and the main country is
france after that spain portugal brazil
united kingdom united states germany
after three years portugal will now go
on its own without financial help the
exit comes just as the european
parliament election is set to begin
our prime minister
he mentioned that it was it was kind of
euphoric
and
a very nice speech
um trying to
suggest that it was a choice and
portugal was ready to go without no
safety net but in reality it was not a
choice so germany push a lot and other
more developed countries within europe
portugal is returning to the
international finance markets and many
there worry the path will be anything
but smooth
you